Mic is hot. Beautiful. Well, thank you all for
coming. I know we're right here at the, uh,
towards the end of the day. Expo Hall is
closed.
Well, it'll be closed in 30 minutes, so I
appreciate you all spinning the end of this with me.
Um, my name is Alex Dragg.
I work on the, the product and go to market
strategy side here at Kong,
and you'll notice a second name up on the screen, Michael
Field. You'll not see a second speaker.
It's because Michael Field is actually an agent.
He's going to help me give this presentation.
Just kidding.
He's just a co-worker who slacked off
and, and wasn't able to make it.
Um, I was hoping I'd get a laugh, cause, you
know, when the, when the crowd laughs,
I feel so much more comfortable here on stage. I
was able to just, just give me a fake one on 3,
it just makes me feel so much better.
Well, you're so that was OK. I wasn't even on 3. That
was excellent. Awesome. Thank you all.
So anyways,
um, agents,
agents, agents, agents, I'm sure that you
all have heard a lot about them at this event
this year.
Today I'm gonna be talking about.
Building state of the art gente
infrastructure.
Right? Cause this is where we find ourselves. Look,
we're not just talking about agents because it's,
you know, yes, there's a lot of hype,
there's a lot of agent washing, there's no doubt
about that.
But there is a lot of promise here, right? There's
a reason we are accelerating
into this era of AI
agents, right? We've gone across lots of eras,
cloud, developer platform, mobile, whatever,
and now we are finding ourselves hurtling
towards the era of AI agents,
and not for fun.
For these reasons,
Yes, we can have lots of technical
conversations
about the AI agent.
But
they do real things for the business.
They make internal business processes, business
operations a whole lot more efficient, or at least
they can.
They actually, you know, sneak peek to a few slides from now.
They actually aren't really doing that right now for most folks,
but they can, and the promise is there.
We do believe they'll be able to reduce costs for the business,
boost productivity of every single individual
who leverages an agent or teams
of people who are leveraging an agent.
We think there are actual
agent products that will be able to be
built and generate
top line revenue or more top line revenue
and of course increase customer attention, right? There's look, the,
the promise is depending on how deep you wanna go
looking at the business, looking at business value, looking
at the tech, looking at technical value and
process and operations, there's the, the,
the potential really is.
Really, quite honestly unknown,
right? We just, we just don't know how good
this could get.
However,
it's not where we find ourselves.
We think about the promises of these things.
There's 4 numbers up here on the screen, you can
read them all.
But there's one
that I really want to focus on.
It's that 6% number.
When we think about automation, we think about more effective
process, we think about shipping new,
uh, net new generating products
that will drive net new revenue.
Look, it all comes back
to margins for the business.
Alright, everyone in here who's ever had to make a case
to buy buy technology, build something, look,
it comes down to a business case at the end of the day,
and at the end we're looking at margins for the business,
right? Agents
and AI programs
today are decimating these.
So you're 80, it's 84% of companies see
at least a 6% erosion
of net business margins, not AI program
margins, not this one project, not this one
product, gross business margins,
and that's just 84%, and that's just 6%,
which is a lot.
A quarter of companies, and this, I'm not making this up by the
way, there's a real report that, that, uh, that showcases
this. We have a blog about it if you wanna go read it on
the website, but a quarter of them see
greater than 16%.
I mean we're talking about something that's decimating the
fundamentals of business success
and now when I talk about this quite often.
People say, well Alex,
um, look, we're, that's fine,
like we're investing, we're willing to lose some money upfront,
but the reality is like that, that's not why this is happening.
Right, that's not why this is happening.
It'd be one thing if the number one challenge
for cost was, well, we're just, you know, we're
investing a lot of tooling, we're investing a lot of people,
investing in a lot of training, but that's actually not the case.
Right, the case there is it's actually fragmented visibility
across models, model providers, the infrastructure
providers, cloud environments, local
environments, hybrid environments. Nobody knows who's
using what, building what, consuming what, exposing
what, to whom.
It's only gonna get worse as agents proliferate
and sprawl and you know there was a lot of numbers on
or were a lot of numbers on the previous slide around
security we'll talk about that today too for sure and
lo and behold it's also a fragmentation problem.
The vast majority of organizations because look, there's a lot
of talk about it at this event.
AI governance,
majority of organizations, they simply don't have it.
And even if they do,
it oftentimes is just a bunch of memos,
right? It's a bunch of policies
that we say we're gonna follow, we say we're gonna
implement,
it's just
on a document somewhere,
right, not actually implemented, enforced
in the real world at one time, etc. etc.
and what is the result of that? Well,
there's a reason why 20% of all incidents now
are categorized as shadow AI incidents.
8 86% of organizations
are completely blind to how data flows
around,
right? Data moves around, these AI data flows.
And look, I'm not saying that anyone's doing anything
necessarily wrong.
It's hard.
There's a lot we have to do.
It's more than just two things, right? It's gonna get a lot
more complex in a second, I promise.
But it is this, just this part is hard, just knowing the
right model for the job is hard,
right? OK, now
we bring the right model or models. What
about security? What about guard rails? What
about res uh uh quality and
accuracy?
What about scrubbing sensitive data,
PII once again, especially as we
continue to expand the amount of models
that we're using, amount of clients and consumers
who need to leverage these things, amount of data
that we're training these models on.
OK, now we gotta be able to measure stuff, remember
cost.
Well, can we see how many tokens are being consumed
everywhere
and not just on the corporate cards, but all
those engineers that go and start consuming on
their individual personal cars, then expense it
later, right? Can we see all this?
Can we implement things like controls on consumption,
usage of tokens, right, can we rate limit these
things? What about
not just token rate limiting, but something
like semantic cash and caching responses to make
the actual cost of every transaction on
average go down.
Look, I can keep talking about
all the things that we need to do.
Right, there's a lot, it's very hard.
And organizations right now have so many things
that the market, that vendors, guilty
as charged,
are throwing at them, they're having to think about,
right? And that's just the LLM.
The reality is a lot more than that.
When we think
About the agent
We have to think about what
we refer to here at Kong
as the entire agentic data path.
Normally I have a nice little build for the slide, but I just couldn't
get the animation to work. But normally what I would show
is that, yes, you know, people are thinking a lot about this
agent.
So I start with just the agent, right?
So OK, what does the agent need? The agent needs a brain,
needs some reasoning faculty.
LLMs, excellent.
Yeah, let's go slap something in front of the LLMs.
You hear about LLM gateways, AI gateways, there's a
reason those are, those are popular, right? They
can implement some of those controls I just mentioned on the
previous slide, rate, limiting, caching, etc.
OK, the LLM is only trained on so much data.
What is it, if, if, what does the brain need to
make decisions?
It needs context.
It needs extra information from time
to time.
So, here comes MCP to the rescue.
No, actually not, right? MCP is
really good at enabling context. They can fetch
context, mutate context, that's fine.
Where does the context come from?
What provides the context? Well,
we're talking about static data, static
information, this is gonna be an API call most of the time, at least, we
think this is going to be the best pattern so far.
But it's not just static data.
Agents will need to make decisions in real time
with the most up to-date information that they can.
So now we're talking about real-time data, now we're thinking about
event streams, event data,
getting a little bit closer to the direct
data. So it's not
just L LLMs.
The speed issues, the cost issues, the risk
issues.
So all those little squares in the slide before this,
there's a lot to think about for the LLM.
There's a whole lot more to think about across this data
path. How are we going to actually make these things worse,
work?
This gets even more complicated when we're
thinking about all the other agents. We
start thinking about multi-agent architectures, agent
to agent
or agent to agent to agent to agent, right, each
with their own data path to govern, to make cost
efficient, to make secure, make resilient,
right? And to prove my point,
let's just talk about that cost thing again.
If you look at the unexpected AI costs, which
are what are driving these these cost issues so far,
hopefully you can see it's probably a little small for those of you at least in
the back. LLM token
and API costs, that is the, if I
count correctly, the 5th
challenge,
right, for these AI programs.
The 5th,
uh, the 5th,
uh, greatest unexpected AI cost.
So once again, it's a lot more than
just what's going on
with the LLM.
All of the context and connectivity matters. Once
again, LLMs are our brain, they need context,
MCP.
Mutate, fetch,
enable at the end of the day, enable context for more
APIs and events.
Remember what is the challenge, what
is the thing that's driving these problems,
Fragmented visibility.
Not only in consumption of resources.
Visibility into how data moves across
this data path, and it's because we've ended up
here. Right, this is the,
I, this is not me saying everyone, anyone's done
anything, you know, horribly wrong, we've all been experimenting.
We've all been experimenting. And that's good. We have
to experiment. It's really, really good.
But,
look, The
the the problem is fragmentation. We
must unify
these ecosystems.
Right, we've been thinking in, in sort of pockets
right in the API land, which is where Kon has spent most
of our time, right, API management, API gateways.
We've been trying to, you know, talk about this unification
of the API ecosystem, right, but often they look, they
just, the migration can be painful. It seems scary,
right? But now we have a real reason to do that.
Now we have a real reason to think,
at least not a real reason, but more compelling, more,
uh, immediate reason given all these AI use cases
and AI initiatives to unify everything from the
API to the event to the LLM to MCP to
agent to agent, right? We must unify
then this this connectivity.
But it is not
just about implementing the proper technology or
getting rid of other stuff, that's not my point, I'm
not here to pitch at all.
You won't hear me talk about a Kong solution on
the stage. We can talk after if you want, but not up
here. But
remember, fragmentation is the killer,
so how do we go about solving this?
We think it starts by asking the right questions.
Now, I
speak to folks all over the place in the org,
CTOs, you know, Chief Data Officer, the,
the VPs of engineering, to the technical,
the platform teams, the data teams, the
individual app devs,
and what I oftentimes hear.
So we're asking this question a lot.
Right, what applications are we gonna build? What agents
are we gonna use, what frameworks are we gonna use,
right? What are these agents actually going to do? And that's a, that's
a good question. I'm not saying don't ask that question.
They ask this question.
I'll also ask these depending on who you're talking to, what's
going to power these things?
Right, will it be the APIs?
Will it just be MCP? You know, there's been a whole lot of
conversation around there around whether or not MCP is
going to,
uh, eliminate the need for APIs,
right? I, I don't think so,
um, but,
you know, maybe they're asking this question.
Direct data access, real-time data, who knows, right?
There's a lot of questions around this that are being
asked.
But our feeling
is that you don't wanna start there,
right? The reality is like all this is, this is changing
rapidly.
Every week,
there's some new thing someone
is telling you to do,
right? As it pertains to AI
and AI and agentic application development,
right? And so our feeling is that look, no matter what kinds of
applications you'll need to, to use AI to build,
no matter what's going to fuel them.
The relationship will be there, something to
solve.
These things are gonna change a lot on the right
and left.
There is a consistent problem for the
organization to solve, and it is this thing in the middle.
Is this connectivity layer in
the middle, what we call
the connectivity layer of AI
and we think
we've seen in practice with with customers
that when we start here,
we start building a flexible, secure,
reliable, resilient layer that
can adapt to the changes over here on the right and left,
this is when the organization can truly proceed into
this genic era
with confidence.
OK, well that sounds fine. Maybe you believe me, maybe
you don't. If you don't, let's just talk after. I'm gonna
try and convince you.
But if you do, the question should be, what do I do? OK,
what, what is this AI connectivity layer? How do
I approach this?
OK, let's think about what an AI connectivity platform could
look like.
Right, I think about it in terms of 5 pillars.
First pillar,
build pillar.
All these resources, all the fuel, it's
going to power these applications.
We still have to go fast, right? How do we, how do we enable
the builders to quickly design, test,
debug
all these resources, and the integration patterns
and connections between them or between these AI
applications and these resources.
Take something like MCP. How do we, how do we test
the consistency, the reliability, the accuracy
of these transactions?
How do we test the relationship between the server and the API, the
server and the event?
How do we test these things? How do we build these things? How do we ship
these things quickly?
But once again, remember,
security's a problem. Speed, cost, risk. These
are the three things that I talk about all the time. How do we
make sure that we mitigate
risk properly?
This means how do we centrally
and implement
standards
around exposure
of these resources and access
to these resources
for the agents, for these AI applications,
right? Third pillar, discover.
We've built the thing, now we're running the thing, it doesn't mean
that whatever needs to consume it can actually find
it. Right, we've
still not done a good job for the human consumers,
oftentimes.
Right now we have this new kind of consumer, this non-human
consumer, this agentic consumer.
Human consumers will still matter for sure.
Both need to be able to find these things.
For two reasons.
One, for the sake of building on top
of it. So think about for the, the consumption
use case, right? How do I package up
MCP server, how do I package up, um,
or agents even, how do I package up the APIs
and event data as proper self-service
products with all the documentation,
all the self-service registration, the ability to try
it, the ability to have a credentials
provision to start using, once again, all in a self-service,
seamless manner. But that's just the first reason why
discovery matters. The second reason.
Brings us into our 3rd pillar or 4th pillar
rather, is govern.
We have to be able to see everything,
discover what we have across the data
path.
See, is it secure? Does it match up with all
of, are you doing the things that match up with all those
uh bullet points on those governance memos?
Right, are we doing security the way that we've agreed upon? Are we doing
resilience the way that we've agreed upon?
Dirty little secret of MCP is that right now it's
actually not that much of a secret based on the conversations
I've had.
We've got a lot of individual engineers running around
spinning up their own MCP servers on their local
machines.
Do we have to do that, we have to go through that phase.
Don't get me wrong.
Once again, we're experimenting, we're figuring this stuff out, but
what about standards for MCP server
generation, server development?
We have to be able to find these things.
Measure these things,
measure specifically their compliance with our standards,
and then automate best practices and guardrails
once again across the entirety of the data
path. This brings us
To the 5th pillar.
I'm realizing I'm blowing through this, you all will not
be here for an hour unless everyone,
anyone has a question, but monetize, there's
plenty to say about this.
Remember that margin's erosion number.
When people here,
especially API monetization, they think revenue.
So some folks will think chargeback for sure. Both
matter, right? Both of these things matter.
We must,
if we're gonna fix the margin problem,
first
start with proper cost governance.
Yes, this can be charged back and cost sharing
internally,
but it starts with being able to see consumption.
Define entitlements for these various
resources. Remember all the resources LLMs,
the agent,
LLMMCP API event.
Define entitlements,
meter in real time, I cannot.
Emphasize enough how much that real-time
qualification matters. We can't
wait a week,
right, to see how many tokens have been consumed,
how many APIs have been called, how many times.
Real-time metering against those entitlements.
And then be able to pair that with enforcement
and control.
Must be able to see it,
measure it,
enforce
controls
in relation to accordance with what you see and what you measure.
But that's just the cost control. Remember, margins has that
other part which is top line revenue gen, right?
It's our belief that there's a massive monetization
potential here. I think that
every single white line
on that data path slide earlier
is potential monetization, depending on of course the
space, the use case, the potential consumer. I
was talking to, uh,
I was out in Australia, uh,
for about 2.5 weeks, about 2, 3-ish
weeks ago, speaking to a lot of organizations
about what they're doing with, with AI
and one of them, it was really interesting.
They're horrified
about the cost implications of
what right now are these external agents. So
there are agents once again external to their
company
that right now are, you know, they're, they're scraping
to go get the information that this
particular, uh, company can provide
or its travel data for the most part.
They know that they wanna expose this stuff in a more
standard manner. They don't wanna do the whole scrapey
eye thing,
right? They want to expose it as proper APIs,
proper MCPs, well, really a BMCP service for the
agents, right?
But they're horrified as to how much this will cost.
So once again, they don't control those external agents,
right? They don't, they don't own those.
They don't build them, they don't see how they're built,
right? They're so, they're so
horrified horrified about how much this costs and controlling
the cost of this, this resource consumption that didn't
even take a second to ask them, could we actually make
money from this.
Clearly these agents that are being built, they need this
data. I could probably
charge for that,
right? Maybe, not all the time, but maybe.
And we talked through this and it turns out, yes, there actually might be
a very interesting use case here for
them. So let's approach margins
from both ends, and it's not just the MCP server.
Once again you think about that.
If you are an organization that has a
nice
unified governed API program
and those APIs are sitting there exposing a bunch of business
logic and data.
Any consumer
might need an agent or whatever else,
or MCP server,
monetization potential.
So once again, when you're building your platform,
all five matter.
Build, run, discover,
govern,
monetize,
right? Oh,
supposed to be an animation. Oh well.
The thing we're supposed to say, but it must be unified,
it must be unified.
Remember
the statistics from earlier margins erosion,
cost issues, risk issues. It's
a fragmentation problem.
We can continue experimenting with a bunch of different
tools, but at the end of the day,
the banker will call at some point,
right? We have to clean this up. We have to
think about how we take a unified approach to all five
of these pillars.
I have some perspectives as to to how
organizations can do this.
Once again, like I said, I'm not gonna pitch,
we can talk after
or we can talk about it any questions at the end because hopefully
you'll have some.
But I'm going to leave you with
this. Once
again, speed,
we want to go fast.
I agree. Uh, the business that figures this stuff out
first, they stand to gain
a lot.
I sort of talk in terms of what I call this agentic
AI innovation flywheel,
right, where if you are the
organization that can get your stuff out to market
first
but also not have to roll a bunch of stuff back
or pay a bunch of fines and fees
due to compliance issues and breaches.
And or spend all the money that it takes, right,
to go fix something after it's been rolled out into production, especially
some big glaring issue.
So if you go fast,
balance with cost, balance with risk.
But your competitor
doesn't do that and they just go fast
and they have to do all those rollbacks and pay all those fines,
right? The organization that gets there right first,
well, they get out, they stay out,
they gobble up more market share, which means
better top line, better margins, more investment
into the speed cost risk, more investment in the speed
cost risk, you see what happens on the opposite
side. I call it the
agentic innovation death spiral
where you go out,
you don't prioritize these things,
right? You have to roll back, spend all this money,
you lose market share,
which means that, well, now we have less money to put into these
programs and so on and so forth,
right? So speed
alone,
just a fast way to fail.
Speed, cost, risk
across five pillars, across the data path.
Defragment
We must defragment,
at least in some capacity.
I'm not saying it's easy,
but the early research says that this is where we have to
go. How do we do this,
2 things unify visibility, yes.
A lot of people and when I show that data path slide, they'll
say, OK, well we have monitoring. It's like, OK, that's great.
Do monitoring, do observability, that's awesome.
But you must unify visibility of these things and
enforcement
of controls, best practices, guardrails.
And I'll actually leave you with this.
This is a quote, not for me,
oops, but
from that report,
the 2025 state of AI cost governance report
where I got all these numbers on margins erosion
and what's causing it.
This is the whole flywheel and
death spiral concept in a quote, right?
Stakes couldn't be higher.
AI genic stuff is going from nice to have
to must have, at least it will.
The folks that master these things
will protect the margins while competitors watch profits disappear.
I'm not trying to be a doomer.
I might sound like one.
But I'm not. Look,
This is a massive opportunity. This is not just talking
about how bad
things are. This means that
everyone's struggling with this.
Everyone's having a hard time.
Once again, the opportunity is for the organizations that
can get it right,
right? They're the ones that,
quite frankly, I, I think stand to dominate the
space in the specific industry and verbal
vertical that they're in.
Which is something that is,
especially a lot of times technical teams who are trying to
figure out how to get internal buy-in, right,
get budget,
uh, get influence to go build these things. What's
something we can take to the top, right? This is
something that could define
the next decade
of the businesses, the companies that you all work at, you
all work at's success.
That's all I got.